I just think that the,
the criminal line withdrawn way too far.
I mean,
uh,
my,
my colleagues and friends who are in the
Chicano movement in the southwest often
say,
look,
we didn't cross the border.
The border crossed us,
right?
We were here then.
Then America came,
so don't call us immigrants.
Well,
similar thing happened with crime,
right?
It's not so much that we became more
criminal,
is that more things became criminal.
One way to think about it is that during
Jim Crow,
right?
Simply being black in public space with
criminal activity,
right?
So going to a movie theater and sitting
in the downstairs instead of upstairs
was a crime,
right?
Drinking out of the wrong water fountain
was a crime.
Fitting in the front of the bus was a
crime.
Now we look at those things now and
think,
well that's,
that's ridiculous,
right?
The d,
these are clearly just patterns of
people's lives and behavior.
These are things that we think of is
freedom of choice and the right to
assemble.
And so how could we have thought of them
as criminals?
So the the line of what constitutes
crime is socially constructed can move
back and forward.
Right.
My parent's relationship with the
criminal relationship in the state of
Virginia where I grew up three years
before we came there,
so I mean three years before we moved to
Virginia,
my parents relationship was in fact a
criminal relationship.
So what I know for certain is that we
can change what constitutes crime.
And then in doing so we don't make a
world that is more dangerous.
I think we actually make a world that is
more free so we can say that we are as
unconcerned with inner city high school
kids smoking pot at the bus stop as we
are about Princeton kids getting drunk
to the point of killing brain cells.
Every Thursday night we can just simply
say,
you know what?
These are not activities that make us
afraid.
We are not afraid of young people were
not afraid of the choices that they're
making that we don't have to police
every single activity to the point of
incarceration,
that we can have laws on the book that
stamps sort of our,
our social code.
About what matters,
but that we do not have to police them
at the same level.
We don't in fact have to kind of fill
our jails with people who are doing
petty property,
excuse me,
petty drug crime,
right?
Petty drug crime does not require the
kinds of massive incarceration that it's
currently getting.
We can talk about property crime,
we can talk about sort of,
um,
you know,
physical crimes,
a rape and,
but those things,
by the way,
have all been into Kline as we have
grown our prison population in terms of
petty drug crime.
There is no war on drugs is a war on
sort of petty drug users.
And I think we could,
we could make a choice not to be in that
war.